it's March in Mozambique I'm wearing one
of those one-size-fits-all safety vests
and I have on my steel toed boots
I'm planted in front of a crowd of 20
dusty miners we're in a hot crowded
conference room as their equipment
supplier I've been invited to advise
them on how they might improve their
operation I captivate my audience with a
warm smile on my face is warmth a
weakness just the opposite with this
crowd it is the secret to success
two days later and I'm in a meeting in
Johannesburg with suited executives the
assignment is the same but this time I
command my audience with a polished
confidence as a leader is it better to
be respected or liked powerful or
empathetic feared or loved in the year
1513 Machiavelli advocated for fear over
love he also never had to face a 360
degree review 500 years later I propose
that we need to be both respected and
likes to be effective leaders there
appears to be a tension between these
attributes but they are not mutually
exclusive strength and warmth exist on a
continuum in both of the cases that I
described
I was acting within the realm of my
authentic self by knowing my audience I
could fluidly move along the continuum
to a place that allowed me to be
influential but why these two qualities
strength and warmth anyway they are the
two most important traits in influencing
your audience in fact the field of
psychology credits over 90% of the
positive and negative impressions we
form about others back to strength and
warmth strength is confidence
credibility warmth approachability high
when we judge someone these are the
qualities that we are looking at we
admire leaders who are fluent in using
both strength and warmth because we know
it's not easy there are things that get
in the way he does it complicate our
ability to authentically engage strength
and warmth one of those things anxiety
standing here at the front of the room I
have the privilege of influencing how
you my audience feels now this feels a
bit stressful so I have extra
testosterone strength hormone but this
extra testosterone by definition is
inhibiting my oxytocin warmth hormone
and if that's not enough my cortisol is
high too because of stress and that's
undermining my strength to sum it up
feeling anxious and the overwhelming
chemistry becomes surging with it won't
allow me to project either strength or
warmth we feel anxious in situations
where we want to make a good impression
what we need to do though is learn to
manage our anxiety your best bet the
next time you're in a stressful
situation like this work with the
chemistry breathe and smile both taking
a deep breath and smiling will help
repair up your cortisol levels we need
to manage anxiety to use the strength
warmth continuum in the first place but
once we have that under control how can
we make our continuum as ample as
possible well we need to extend
ourselves to cultivate the maximum
amount of strength and warmth as
authentically possible my career has
been at a mature company so mature in
fact that it will be celebrating 90
years next month
and in my rather large division about
4,000 people I was the first woman to go
to the field and work in sales and the
only reason that I survived that
assignment is because I learned how to
balance strength and warm and to dial up
both to the maximum that I could was
still ice entity being myself
it all started when
I chose mining engineering on my
University application who does that
well not very many 17-year old girls
female enrollment runs it just under 12
percent
I noticed but it didn't bother me
my small supportive cohort from the
comfortable environment I felt like I
belonged I felt completely free to be
myself and it turns out the time I spent
in that space was really important to
developing my confidence when I
graduated from university the prospect
of working in a male-dominated field
well I didn't see it as an issue at all
I went on to work in mining machine
sales in South America think bright
yellow truck the size of a two-story
house that cost six million dollars if
you're thinking that the space is short
on female role models it is in fact when
my company offered me the position my
boss shared with me that not everybody
supported my promotion many didn't
believe that as a woman I could be
successful in that environment I felt
completely betrayed I thought about all
the chatter that was going on around me
about me and I let my confidence get
displaced by self-doubt but as I started
to organize my move from Miami to San
Paolo I started to change
I made the intentional decision to
represent myself with all of the
confidence and confidence that I had and
it was essential to control four biases
like being a woman which was articulated
ever so clearly to me but also for other
biases that I hadn't thought about like
being a foreigner or not having field
experience and when they're probably all
of us have faced being the youngest
person in the room instead of suffering
with these biases I developed a thick
skin and move forward at the same time
though I found a great niche for myself
using warmth to its fullest potential in
an aggressive competitive environment
imagine you run into me at the world's
largest iron ore
in the Amazon jungle it's the rainforest
so I'm drowning in mud I'll have on my
rubber boots in the distance you can see
my bright yellow hard hat with my blonde
ponytail bouncing underneath and a
bright smile on my face now my gender
and the Scandinavian phenotype are not
especially common in the Amazon much
less in the pit of an iron ore mine I
had the great opportunity to play
against type the curiosity that it
created was a means to connect with
people and build relationships
well it sounds nice to dial up strength
and warmth to navigate challenging
situations it's not always easy maybe
like me you fail to find the confidence
to speak up in an important client
meeting or in the same meeting found it
impossible to empathize with artistic
economy if you find yourself missing one
or the other
remember that they are not mutually
exclusive when you feel composed and in
control you can project comfort and
warmth after all the overarching
objective as a leader is not to simply
control your audience or to make them
feel them but to influence them by
managing our anxiety we've cleared the
first hurdle to using the strength
warmth continuing from there we can work
on making it as ample as possible by
maximizing the amount of strength and
warmth that we show the next time you
walk into a room whether you're facing
dusty coal miners suited executives or
something else entirely ask yourself the
question how will I balance strength and
warmth